[Music]
i
grew up mormon
it was mormon most of my life up until a
few years ago
i then left the mormon church and that
is a
whole story that i want to talk about
today with all of you
my purpose in doing this is to share my
perspective
so that anyone who is in a situation
like i was a couple of years ago
who is questioning and wondering can
have another perspective to lean on
i'm not looking to get into debates or
to
talk about the history or the theology
of the church
i'll do that in future videos today all
i want to do is tell you the story of
how
and why i left the mormon church 23rd of
may
2009
i grew up mormon both my parents were at
mormon or lds
latter-day saints i grew up going to
mormon youth camp i then eventually
served a two-year mission in tijuana
mexico
where for two years i went around
and spoke to people in spanish about the
church
and learned a lot learned to speak
spanish fluently
keris how you feel malicious
i then went to the mormon university
called brigham young university in provo
utah where i graduated
i went through all mormon rituals in the
church and temple
i worked in the temple as a volunteer
for a time
i was very very mormon and i believed it
i believed deeply in the unique doctrine
of the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints which
is a christian organization unlike any
other christian organization in its
doctrine
[Music]
the story of how i decided to leave this
really begins with the birth
of my son
[Music]
isabel who also grew up mormon and i got
married in the temple which is a huge
mormon ritual it's a huge part of being
in the church
we got married in the temple we went
back to byu together and
a few weeks before we graduated from byu
we had a baby or izzy had a baby i
didn't have a baby
she had a baby then we took finals and
graduated like literally two weeks later
here we are literally in our cap and
gown with henry who is like
two weeks old after we graduated we
moved
out to washington dc and that's when my
wheels really started to turn
i started to think you know i have a
child now i have to decide how i raise
this child and what i teach him about
the world
i think having henry really made me
wonder and think about how i should
teach him about the world
i had grown up with this firm conviction
of
the lds doctrine and its beliefs about
the world which are very specific
and very peculiar and
i really started to question is this
what i want to teach my son and the
answer
initially was yes i want to teach him
everything that i know about this
faith because i really believed it so
we're moving out to washington dc
and i realized that if i'm going to
teach this to my son i need to
double down on my faith i need to go
deeper than i
ever have and really really establish a
strong foundation
and conviction around this doctrine i
had one but i knew it needed to be
stronger if i was going to teach my son
this
one of the things i loved about mormon
doctrine at the time
was that there was always a push to ask
god if it was true
not to trust any people or any
organization but to like get on your
knees
and say god is this true is this is this
church actually real
is that all of the things that they say
actually
the real deal i had kind of taken
advantage of that promise before but
never really
i had always been in a setting of
pressure whether it was my home
as a kid or my mission or
byu in other words there was always an
incentive to believe
so i'd never really been in a situation
where i could truly
ask this question and not feel like
there was some price to pay
if i decided i didn't believe being in
washington dc with my child
out on my own in the workforce was my
opportunity so i spent an entire year
reading the book of mormon going to
church i had a responsibility at church
that i was
putting a lot of work into and praying
every morning and every night
for some sort of conviction i said i am
more earnest and sincere than i've ever
been about this
i'm willing to listen to any answer i
just need
an answer i spent a year doing this a
year
it's a long time and then i remember
this day i was biking
into washington dc
um on a sunny like spring day and
it just hit me in some really strong way
that
no this isn't working
i've put in the years of asking and the
effort
towards making this work
and it wasn't working this isn't true
for me and like a switch
it just so much came out
of me and i quickly decided
that i was done i don't think it was all
at once i think i had been slowly moving
in this direction for a long time
but in a moment of clarity it clicked
for me
in a very satisfying and like very true
way
so is who is is he isabelle whatever you
want to call her my wife
it didn't click for her she was not on
this journey that i was on
and i came back and i told her i said i
think i am done
being mormon and i had always been the
sort of more devout
convicted mormon and she was just like
what like you just like have decided to
be out of the church and she
she full on said like this this is gonna
end our marriage
like you can't just leave the church and
i just told her i said this is where i
stand and this is what i feel and i felt
very strongly about it
luckily soon enough izzy was on her own
path
of reconciling her thoughts about the
church
her qualms with the church and soon she
would join me
in this path towards leaving the church
now i call it a path because that's
exactly what it is
leaving any orthodox religion is not
easy
there are layers and layers of
psychological and
cultural conditioning that you don't
even realize is there until you start to
peel it back
so even though we started to leave the
church we were still going to church
every sunday which i don't really
understand in retrospect all i can say
is that like
we were just that's what we did every
sunday we went to church and there was
some guilt if we didn't go to church and
so we went to church
but we slowly started to feel an
emptiness towards it
and over the course of six months we
finally decided to stop going to church
my behavior didn't change all of a
sudden like
i didn't leave the church so i could
start drinking alcohol or
coffee or smoking like that was not a
part of the agenda for me
i kind of just carried on exactly how i
had always been
except for now i looked around in the
world and i didn't have
a doctrinal theological framework to
understand it
which was at once exhilarating and
horrifying at the same time my
existential view had been
so neatly packaged by the plan of
salvation which is the key doctrinal
framework within the mormon church
and that was now gone i had no plan i
had no framework to make sense of the
world
exhilarating but horrifying there was
also a deep
fear of the cultural and social
repercussions of my decision
most of my friends were still lds or
mormon
and of course my family was too so was
izzy's
and let me just try to give you a
perspective on why this is such a big
deal
a quick primer on mormon theology is
that
our whole purpose in life is to come
down here to earth
to learn and to grow and to progress and
to attain knowledge
and to fulfill certain
we call them covenants or rituals there
are four of them
that are really important to do while
you're on earth
baptism confirmation this hour-long
ritual inside the temple and then
called the endowment and then the
ceiling or marriage
if you can do those four things then
you're in really good shape you have the
knowledge necessary to go
back and live in the top tier of heaven
and yes
in mormon theology there are multiple
tiers of heaven
if you're not able to get these rituals
done while you're on earth
no worries when you're in the next life
people on earth can do all the rituals
for you
while when you're dead and then you can
have those the chance to
accept those rituals or those covenants
when you're on the other side
it's a huge deal i had gone through all
of the rituals
i had accepted all of those covenants
which are very serious covenants you
wear undergarments that are symbolic
of those covenants that you've made
people call them like
secret underwear or whatever but it was
just religious clothing that
symbolizes your commitment to these
doctrines and the beauty of all of this
within mormon doctrine is
if you do this and everyone in your
family does this then all of you are
sealed together
in this never-ending chain of eternal
family
that is at the epicenter of mormon
doctrines if you know mormons and you
know that they are family centered
it's because of this the whole doctrine
is based on
creating family units that are all tied
into this this covenant these promises
that
bind you that seal you together for time
and all eternity
if you've accepted those covenants and
then you leave
you break away you reject those
covenants you take off your garments
you say i'm done with this
that's a pretty big deal within the lds
framework
you are no longer able to be with your
family in the celestial glory
of the top tier of heaven so if you
believe that
and you're a parent and you see your
child rejecting those covenants
rejecting that eternal ceiling to the
family you're basically seeing your
child
go away and
you feel like you're losing them so
unsurprisingly people leaving the mormon
church creates huge upset within
families
like many other religions it's not just
an insular cultural experience
it is a deeply held doctrinal
theological belief
that if you leave the church there are
major consequences
luckily i had parents who
by the time i told them that i was
leaving the church were very open and
loving
and accepting of my decision certainly
it was hurtful for them but they did not
project that onto me
in any way that made me feel ostracized
unfortunately that
is not the case for a lot of my friends
a lot of other people who have left the
church
but even still with parents who were
accepting
and loving despite my decision
i still had years of purging and
processing to do something that
continues to this day
now four or five years later what i
didn't realize is that
i had internalized a lot of assumptions
of shame and guilt and fear
and judgment that i didn't even realize
i had
and for the years following leaving the
church
it was a process of slowly purging
and peeling back and processing those
things i went through the mr nice guy
phase which is a very common thing for
people who leave the lds church which is
like
i'm just leaving the church nice and
peaceful i'm going to not
be mean i'm not going to be spiteful
towards the church because
in the church when you're in it there's
sort of this like
like archetype of the spiteful angry
anti-mormon who goes out and spreads
lies about the church and they're just
offended and
angry and and i didn't want to be that
person i don't want to be that archetype
and so i tried to maintain very cordial
relationships with everybody
i tried to be super nice like you know
the church was really great for me and
and yet i just you know disagreed with
it so i walked away i went through that
phase for a couple of years
but through therapy and through a lot of
thinking about this i
came to understand that i actually had
some
deep problems and anger towards the
church
and what it instilled in me i had anger
and resentment towards a lot of the
authority structures
that made me feel unclean or dirty i had
anger towards the systems that made me
feel like obedience was the most
important thing that submission
to allah from god was much more
important than
self-expression and self-actualization
i developed a resentment towards the
church structure that
has very homophobic and heteronormative
and misogynistic
structures that taught me to think in
those terms
a church that purports to love everybody
but deeply
condemns certain people because of who
they love
i'd rewire so much of that upon leaving
and perhaps most frustratingly and maybe
this is going to be hard to
communicate the nuance to to someone
who's not lds but
i felt deep frustration at the church's
claim to have a monopoly
over the fullness of truth that the few
million
members are the only keepers of the real
truth of what god wants today for us and
that everyone else has truth too
but through prophets and apostles and
modern-day revelation
the mormons are actually the ones who
have the full picture
they know what's going on i believed
that they had the truth
that was going to deliver me and my
family to eternal bliss
in celestial glory i believed that and i
modeled my life
around it deep into my adulthood
and i feel resentment that i did that
and that the stakes were so high for
leaving
for expressing myself and my qualms for
this doctrine
because after all if you question it
you're questioning
prophets people who are talking to god
you can't do that
it all left me very confused and
required a lot of healing and processing
in that is still going on and let me
just be clear about something this isn't
my millennial brain
trying to reject authority structures
and
subvert old institutions like it's
happening in a lot of religious contexts
right now a lot of people are leaving
religion
i wasn't trying to get away from some
disciplined structure my life is still a
disciplined structure i still have
a lot of the artifacts from my mormon
upbringing what i was fleeing
when i left the mormon church was a
structure that
i feel like put down who i really was
made me cover it up in the name of a
broader vision of what righteousness is
and what jesus wants me to do
it wasn't me it was harmful towards me
and it was harmful towards others
and the consequences were severe if you
spoke up
and you challenged the status quo the
culture is not one of discourse and
debate
it's one of obedience obedience
obedience
obedience obedience is a hallmark
belief and tenet of the lds experience
and as a member you feel it leaving the
church
is painful socially mentally
you experience a cost for doing so and
if you're in that situation now
which i know some of those watching are
where you know that your family
and your peers will think differently of
you
if you decide to leave
just know that it's a lot better on the
other side if you choose yourself
and you choose your personal experience
and your personal expression
and you honor that as opposed to
honoring the fear of obedience
there's some years of pain and
adjustment but there is a sense of
freedom
on the other side this is uncomfortable
for me to say even right now i'm
imagining
whether it's family or friends who are
still
active believers in the church watching
this i can feel that discomfort even now
years later of what are they thinking of
me
making this video and and effectively
talking to others who might be in the
church and telling them to leave
that that old archetype of the bitter
ex-mormon who's polarizing
and an extremist is is is ringing in my
ears
and yet day by day those voices and
those old models
they dissolve more and more and they
become
less loud and they become less part of
my identity i
for many years did identify as someone
who used to be mormon and now i'm not
but yet with time i'm slowly developing
my own new identity
that isn't pinned to my reactionary
experience with the church but it's just
pinned to who i am what i love
i'm a father who loves my children i
love to learn about the world and
explore and explain things i love
film i love animation i love moss i love
cooking
i love reading stories to my boys and
teaching them
about the world i love traveling i love
trains
i love science i love the beauty of our
world
and the mystery that it is and the
mystery of life
and cultures that appreciation
is enough for me i don't have a
spiritual framework
to fill the vacuum i haven't joined some
religion
maybe someday i will maybe i'll develop
that but for now
the wonder of the world outside of the
plan of salvation
and god looking out over his children
for this big plan of obedience
outside of that i feel like there is
plenty to
stand in awe of and love without
a god and a savior to create meaning
for me and yet there's a strange paradox
within all of this that
i have to talk about which is the mormon
experience
also gave me so much my mission
while i feel conflicted about what i was
doing and how i was doing it
i learned to work hard i learned to
speak spanish
i learned to navigate in cultural
experiences outside of my own
i was in tijuana for two years next to a
giant
international border one of the most
violent and intense borders on earth
and that instilled a love for the
stories of people who live near borders
which
helped create my career my parents
raising me
in that environment gave me beautiful
experiences
and community taught me how to be
industrious and hardworking and
disciplined
it taught me how to care and love and
serve others
those are all good things so how do i
reconcile
the pain and the
psychological confusion that this
organization
brought to my life packaged tightly with
the reality of all of the beautiful
things that i brought to my life
the good the community the memories
the values of honesty and service in
love
that's a paradox that will probably be
with me forever
it's impossible to summarize this
experience as one
thing good or bad and
that's okay that dissonance is okay so
that's a little bit of my story
and my thoughts around why i left the
mormon church i want to hear from you
especially those who have experience
with this and can
speak about the complexities i also want
to hear from those who have questions
and are worried or scared this isn't an
easy decision i also want to hear
from those who have experience with this
whether it's from the mormon church or
any other
orthodox insular religion or culture
breaking out of those systems is hard
and sometimes not worth it
but sometimes it is sometimes it's worth
it and sometimes
on the other side of that hard journey
there is a much brighter future
hey thanks for listening everybody um
before you go
i want to thank today's sponsor audible
which is
something i've been using for it feels
like
eight years of my life audible is a
giant repository
of amazing audiobooks and other audio
content
i learned so much on audible and i am
really grateful that it exists
the way it works is you subscribe as a
member
you get one credit every month and you
can choose any audio book
in the entire library there are tens of
thousands of titles to choose from
i listen to audible books when i'm
researching a story to make me feel more
informed about
the story that i'm working on as well as
just for
fun like i'm listening to this book
right now called
project hail mary by andy ware it's like
an accessible sci-fi audiobook and it's
just so
delightful and the reader is so good the
performance he does all these accents
and like
it's just such a joy to listen to and
it's not just one audio book a month
that you can get which has
been plenty for me but now they give you
access to this plus catalog
which is filled with thousands and
thousands of audiobooks
original entertainment guided fitness
and meditation
sleep tracks and podcasts that are ad
free
and some that are totally exclusive to
audible so you can be going through the
plus catalog
all of this is included with your
membership in addition to the credit
that you get to to get an audio book
for me this has been a no-brainer for
literally almost a decade
i've been a member because audible just
makes a lot of sense
it's how i learn about the world you can
try all of this for 30 days
for free without paying any money so go
to audible.com
johnny harris or text johnny harris to
the number 500 500
to get in on this giant repository of
audio content
thank you audible for sponsoring this
video and thank you all
for watching this more personal video um
i hope it was helpful to some of you
and i will see you all in the next video
which is going to be
an explainer so buckle up for that see
ya